you know you could just ask her out the
beauty from Harvard Law the blue color
fed from the wrong side of Brooklyn
don't be a dick let's go LAPD just found
an unidentified female body in a garage
dumpster but we don't yet guy's body
appears to have been bleached inside and
out hey what is it this is the guy the
death penalty could be too good for him
what guy I can't have you questioned
you're letting him go aren't you I'm
sorry
he's guilty we can't just let him walk
I'm gonna get him no matter what it
takes
pray yes I found how did you find him
online 696,000 Caucasian males in the US
prison system you can cycle through the
entire population in a year if you look
at nineteen hundred and six phases every
night so I did for a year for thirteen
years reopen the case we've had multiple
leads have all been false alarms ingest
dies a little bit every single time I
don't have the stomach to watch him walk
away again maybe we go about this
littlest officially
justice I owe my daughter that we gotta
find this guy before Jasper
my daughter was the thing that made me
me
nothing will ever change that she's not
gonna stop he didn't quit his job he can
change his name
his car
but I will still find him
you